that's what I said we should fight one
another for the honor of leadership
it sounds fair it's not necessary no
okay I got some blasters unless you guys
want to use knives oh yes please use
knives no not anchored there should be
no knifing one another everybody knows
it was in charge me yes oh yeah eleven
are there any Thor stories and he wants
to do before he unless the character go
meeting beta ray bill maybe that was one
of the first groups are the first comics
I've ever read
yeah I love that I just hope they you
know keep let me have another crack at
it you know I have had so much fun with
it and it doesn't feel at all it doesn't
feel old to me you know it feels more
fresh now than it did you know the first
couple of times I applied it and so to
be sure to reinvigorate it with with the
character and the world and feel like we
have some no boundaries now we can
really sort of take it anywhere is
pretty exciting point to be in welcome
back everyone it's Charlie we have brand
new Thor for love and thunder to break
down Chris Hemsworth did a big comic-con
panel over the weekend revealing the
future of the Thor character through
Marvel phase four in beyond into Marvel
phase 5 we're doing a blu-ray giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best Thor for
theory on the video I know there's a lot
of questions about the timeline if the
guardians are gonna show up during Thor
4 because now that movie is happening
before guardians of the galaxy vol 3
whereas before we just assume the Thor
was gonna show up during guardians 3
when we thought that that was gonna
happen first but just going down the
list of all the things that he talked
about just starting with the beta ray
bill stuff because so many people so
many big comic book fans have been
asking for beta ray bill to actually
show up in a movie not just as an easter
egg like during Thor
but actually show up as a real character
without coming right out and saying yeah
we're totally doing this he's implying
that they do have plans to do beta ray
bill that was one of the first scripts
and first comic books that he read when
he was doing the character so you find
out about all these details of the
previous Thor movies that you never knew
about if you've never heard stories
about the original version of that first
Thor movie they actually did have a
version of Baldur in that they could
always introduce them in a future movie
if they want but they've kind of already
done the secret sibling twist with the
hella character so I don't know that
they would race to do Baldur
oh yeah there's another secret brother
that your father never told you about
but if it wasn't clear beta ray bill
actually has already been introduced in
the Marvel movies during Thor Ragnarok
it's just that you haven't actually seen
him on screen there was an early version
of him that they put into Thor Ragnarok
in the contest of Champions in the
grandmasters games
that's why his head showed up on the
grandmasters Tower here because at one
point he was one of the champions Kevin
Feige later said that they felt like
they weren't doing the character justice
and it was a little too much already
that they were putting in the film so
they cut him out and said we'll just put
him in a future movie when we can
actually do a really good job with the
character so before they announced Thor
for love and thunder I think a lot of
people myself included assumed that that
would probably be through the guardians
of the galaxy films because beta ray
bill is a cybernetic being in a
korbinite which is kind of a weird
concept to sell to people but I feel
like the guardians of the galaxy movies
have always done a really good job with
selling you really weird characters in
really cool ways just look at the
guardians 3000 team from the
post-credits scenes
I miss you guys so much
what say we still so [ __ ] if they could
do a really good job with those
characters they can totally slam-dunk
beta ray bill but now that Thor for love
and thunder really is happening before
Guardians 3 it's just another
opportunity to introduce that character
regardless of whether or not he's a
major character or just a side character
or somebody they introduced at the end
of the movie then he shows up during the
guardians of the galaxy or another space
based franchise because you guys have
been really excited by this - one of the
first beta ray bill stories was actually
an OVA story so he was actually
transporting his people to a new land
because their former home had been
destroyed by a Serdar and the fire
demons during that journey they
encountered Richard Ryder Nova Nova is
supposed to be coming during Marvel
phase 4 Marvel phase 5 they haven't said
exactly when they just said that they're
working on a movie for the character but
because there's so many more cosmic
films that they're working on and Marvel
phase 4 is going so cosmic that's why
they had the Spider Man far from home
post credits scene with Nick Fury on the
sword Space Station because the Avenger
stuff the really big stuff are moving
into the cosmic realm of MCU that's
where you get to Nova Silver Surfer
Fantastic Four Galactus the other really
big MCU cosmic stories and really weird
space baek's characters that they just
have not gotten to yet Thor 4 is a story
all about Natalie Portman's character
turning into the female version of Thor
like Jason Aaron's Mighty Thor run beta
ray bills origins story in the Marvel
comics is kind of the same thing after
he's turned to this cybernetic being he
winds up defeating Thor in combat then
Odin declares that they'll duel each
other he beats Thor again but spares his
life
that's when Odin declares him worthy and
gives him his own hammer called storm
breaker
now obviously it looks a little bit
different from MCU storm breaker but
Thunderstrike is also another hammer
that Thor wielded in the comics if they
don't want to get too confusing with
things they could just call his hammer
thunder strike because it's the fourth
Thor film everyone has theories about
what they might do to the character
because so many MCU actors are either
retiring or just quietly walking off
into the distance some of them are
getting phased for projects like Hawkeye
is getting the Hawkeye phase four series
but at this panel Chris Hemsworth said
that he wanted to keep playing the Thor
character as long as they would keep
having him
which makes it sound like they
definitely do not plan on killing him
off during Thor 4 means that we can
still get a Marvel phase 5 Thor Avengers
5 movie and Thor crossing over with
Silver Surfer so you can actually do the
Marvel remake a Point Break
cue the workout tape of him losing all
that weight before Thor for right now
the Marvel movies still move in real
time meaning spider-man far from home
comes out a couple months after avengers
endgame but the events of that movie
also take place a couple months after
the end of Tony Stark's funeral at the
end of endgame so because Thor for love
and thunder is coming out November 2021
that's a little over two years after the
end of endgame meaning the Thor for love
and thunder will pick up a couple years
after the end of Avengers endgame giving
them a couple years to fly around the
cosmos looking for that version of
Gamora from 2014 so Peter quill can win
her over to the team and giving Thor
plenty of time on that Bowflex that
star-lord said he was going to buy
during infinity war
[Music]
if the Guardians really do show up
during Thor 4 but they'll probably do is
just show up at the beginning to address
what they've been doing together or Thor
will just show up back on planet Earth
because he can open the Bifrost with
Stormbreaker he technically doesn't need
a spaceship to get around the universe
and if they don't want to include them
in the movie they'll just have him
reference what they've been doing that
whole time or make some jokes about what
they were up to in the past couple of
years when he comes back to Asgard to
meet with Valkyrie I've seen a lot of
good Jane Foster Thor theories but the
way they talk about the movie is gonna
be our version of Jane Foster not one
from an alternate reality they haven't
said much about including Loki but I do
have a feeling that because his series
is happening before Thor for love and
thunder because the Disney Plus series
are all supposed to set up what's going
on in the movies and Loki has the
biggest connection with the Thor
franchise early Loki theory because
they're rolling so hard on the concept
of the multiverse during Marvel phase 4
through Doctor Strange in the multiverse
of madness literally a multi burst movie
in the Loki that we know is now in an
alternate reality with the tesseract
causing all kinds of problems that
version of Loki will also play a role
during Thor for love and thunder and
could be a way for them to bring another
version of Mjolnir into our reality one
that did not get destroyed by hella
there are a lot of people that are also
wondering if Eitri is just gonna forge a
new version of Mjolnir I don't know if I
like that idea though if it's so easy
for them to just make another version I
really like the concept of them invoking
multiverse if they're rolling so hard on
that during the next couple of years the
other really cool thing Kevin Feige
talked about that they're doing with
these Marvel phase 4 movies is setting
up a lot of really big stuff that's
gonna be coming during phase 5 and
beyond so that gets into the concept of
mutants the Fantastic Four the x-men
characters so everybody post your Thor
theories in the comments below but don't
worry because it definitely sounds like
Chris Hemsworth plans on coming back for
Avengers 5 when they decide to do that
movie which I think probably won't be
before 2023 just because it's typically
am a movie in black panther 2 is may
2022 so maybe the year after that
there's a whole bunch of Marvel phase 4
stuff that they're getting ready to
shoot so I will do more videos for those
movies and Disney Plus series as we get
more details leave all your requests in
the comments below Watchmen on HBO is
starting next week - I will be doing
episode videos for that
congratulations zombie bro 9 you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details
everybody click here for my Deadpool 3
Robot Chicken trailer video and click
here for that Batman crisis on Infinite
Earths teaser video thank you so much
for watching everybody stand awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you